what you're about to watch is a clip
from my brand Linux training where I get
together with entrepreneurs thought
leaders who want to build their brand
using YouTube and making data driven
decisions to blow up their Brand This
Year enjoy
we're talking about something that I
haven't talked about inside of brand
Linux but but also just in general I
haven't really talked about ad
strategies yet and I think it's it's
interesting and helpful uh if you have
budget not everybody does when they're
starting their Channel but if you have
budget how can you use it to actually
grow your channel where a lot of people
do it incorrectly I can't tell you how
many accounts I've joined I've looked at
uh where they are just making a disaster
of their ad spend either one just going
completely off the books and not using
Google but using Reddit uh using other
kind of fake sources there's one guy big
big name guy who that was my first call
with him was like wow you're doing civil
your Channel Growing but how come you're
getting you're not getting any subs oh
like we just buy
a bunch of subs and views from Reddit
from Brazil
and then his channel got banned for a
week he's like okay never buy again from
Reddit you know I get that like the
metrics matter and the vanity matters
that you know I get all that but
but like if you're gonna buy views and
buy Subs let's do it in a way that's
actually kosher with with YouTube so
that's what I covered today I'm not
teaching any black cat stuff all of this
stuff is Google approved we're using
Google's own tools to be able to use it
and can really Propel your channel
forward
so I'm going to talk about the different
ad formats in stream versus Discovery so
in stream this is one of the big
mistakes a lot of people make
in stream are the ones that show up
before video usually and also sometimes
in the middle of the video or at the end
of the video
in-stream ads are great if you just want
to get views
think about it you're interrupting
somebody's video so this video this this
is a video that Russell Brunson put out
recently proximity Is Power uh talking
about human Tony Robbins when you click
play you see this before right so
there's two ads that will show up this
is the first one I want to watch Russell
Brunson and Tony Robbins but I'm getting
this ad for Dugout mugs you know I
probably don't care a lot about Dugout
mugs now these are great ads for
conversion
so you know Casey in the house I know
you're you're great at direct response
marketing uh if you have something to
sell
this is actually one of the most cost
effective and efficient ways right now a
lot of the people who are
Facebook ad gurus are moving to YouTube
because there's less restrictions and
it's getting a lot cheaper and these are
the ads that they're doing is this
pre-roll so if you have something to
sell you have a business model attached
to it whether you're running it before
your own videos one of the great reasons
of building an organic YouTube audience
is that then you can run pre-roll ads
against your own channel at a discounted
rate and then sell whatever program
you've got it's at a discounted rate
because you make money from the video as
well so you're paying to be on your own
channel but then you make the money back
on AdSense so if you've got something to
sell is fantastic
and every view anytime somebody goes
past the 15 second mark it counts as a
view
but it doesn't lead to organic growth
for the channel these guys are not going
to be subscribing to the channel so if
I'm sitting here I may watch this ad I
really want to get to this video I'm I'm
I may be trying to skip as soon as
possible but if I go past the 15 second
mark it counts as a view but there's no
place for me to actually subscribe to
Dugout mugs and I'm probably not going
to right because I want to watch this
video with Russell and Tony
so this is where a lot of people are
buying ads and it's just the wrong
method if you want growth for the
channel if you just want views if you
say hey it it's really important that I
get 10 000 views on each video the
cheapest possible right this is the way
to do it
but nobody's going to subscribe to the
channel
so it's just about balancing priorities
and I'm not here to judge you to say how
important views are for your for your
brand and everything else but it will
not help you grow the channel it is
fantastic for selling and pitching your
product the first five seconds of the
video is a pitch for the rest of the ad
because I can skip after five seconds so
you've got to hook me in the first five
seconds to make me want to watch the
rest of the ads and then go buy your
product so the options that I can do
here is learn more you know about about
whatever this program is get uh emotive
or skip the ad but nowhere can I
subscribe to it but this will count as a
view
okay not recommended for channel growth
though
Discovery is the other one okay so
that's called in stream the other is
Discovery those are your two options
in Discovery your ads are showing up as
a suggested View
so they're watching a video
most views you happen on mobile so this
is what it'll look like this is the
watch page you'll see a bunch of videos
underneath and then your ad will show up
right above all the other suggested
videos
this is what you want to be doing
the targeting becomes super important to
make sure you're targeting the Right
audience
but they're opting in to actually watch
the video
so I'm watching this video this was the
the if this was the same video this was
the Russell and Tony video I'm watching
it here underneath I see your video I
still have to click to go and watch it
so I'm opting in versus the the
in-stream ads where I'm being forced to
watch this commercial
so when you're getting a view it's much
more a real View and also leads to a
normal video page this page is leading
to a sales page it's leading me off-site
this page is leading me to a video but
then I can watch I can then subscribe
and so this is how we can get a lot of
Channel growth subscriber growth count
for our audience uh but the target
becomes super important because you can
get your video in front of a lot of
people it doesn't mean it's the right
people just like add buying across any
other platform
so we want to be going for Discovery if
you care about the channel growth so
this is just I need tons of views
but they're not going to ever be buyers
they're not going to subscribe to the
channel this is I care about getting
views and I want to grow my channel get
more subscribers
so I'm going to focus most of this talk
on Discovery we could dive in if you
have questions in the chat or at the end
about in-stream if you want to but
Discovery is how we're going to actually
grow a channel
so if you're if you're trying to create
a discovery campaign YouTube is Google
so you use Google AdWords when you're
creating a campaign
there are no campaigns that you can set
up yet that optimize for channel growth
AdWords was designed to be a conversion
sequence so if you see all the options
you can get sales leads website traffic
brand consideration Etc promote my app
local listings but there is no option
for YouTube subscriber growth
which actually creates an opportunity
because not a lot of people are doing it
so the cost is still relatively low to
be able to get in so we're going to
create a campaign without a goals
guidance and I'm just going to walk you
through kind of Step by Step so that if
you're super familiar with AdWords great
use it if you're not if use a
step-by-step sequence people to do it
next we're gonna go video
continue then we're going to go custom
video campaign
this one we would do for the in stream
if you wanted
a custom video campaign and then here
okay so some of the settings to pay
attention to
these settings can save you a lot of
money if you do it properly okay setting
number one always uncheck video Partners
on the Display Network these are all on
by default
always uncheck this all we care about if
we're trying to grow a channel is being
promoted on YouTube not across YouTubes
in Google's entire display Network other
websites Gmail
Etc we don't be showing up there we only
care about YouTube this one is Hit or
Miss search results
um if you really know your audience and
you really know the keywords that
they're going to be searching for this
means you're going to show up under
search or this one is going to show up
underneath somebody else's video
this is for sure a winner because
they're already watching videos this one
is a little iffy because
we want to not just be a utility Channel
where they're just searching and not
continuing the sequence we want them to
watch multiple videos from our Channel
so when you're showing up here they're
clicking on suggested
now we're bringing in the audience that
loves clicking on suggested videos so
they're more likely to watch another
video in another video in another video
where people who are only on search
don't necessarily always follow that
breadcrumb so you could play with it
this one's going to get you way better
results this one I would just test to
see if you're gonna do it really refine
your keywords and then pay attention to
if your channels are growing or not
location is a whole other discussion so
this is another one when I'm when I'm
talking to
um you know Drew works with clients I
end up just helping my friends who are
most of the biggest people in thought
leadership on YouTube
and when they're looking at growing
their channel the next question becomes
how much do you care about where they
come from
and this is different depending on the
person some people they just want to get
the hundred thousand the one million to
get the plaques to get the you know
prestige a little ego boost
um reputation and they don't care where
it's from
and so if you don't care where your
people coming from it's all countries
and territories
some people really want to build a list
of buyers like hey I want to I want to
sell my stuff to them eventually I want
to sell my subscriptions I want to sell
my consultant I want to sell my programs
courses Etc if you're doing that and
that's your goal then the four these are
the big four easy people go after
Australia Canada UK US those are the
people who have the most money who care
the most about personal development and
are most likely to buy your thing right
so how do you balance it and this is
there's no right answer there's some
people I've worked with it's like I
don't even care about buyers I have my
own business model I figured all that
out I just need for people when they go
to my YouTube channel they see big
numbers of real subscribers not like
fake subscribers that might get me
banned right it's like okay well this is
the way but just turn on all countries
and you'll get
a bunch of people from India and
Argentina and Brazil and Global but
you're not building a North America you
know Australia UK buyer list
um so there's no right answer just
what's the right answer for you and your
business for you right now some people
do a switch it's like okay once I get to
a hundred thousand then I'm gonna switch
over or once I get to a million then I'm
gonna switch over because now I have a
little more Prestige because especially
if you've come from a different industry
and you've had success and you're
starting on YouTube
you don't want to start and only have
800 subscribers so this is a faster way
to be able to go off and do it
other settings always uncheck TV screens
always uncheck TV screens
because
you can get a lot of watch time on a TV
screen because it auto plays to the next
video so some people just leave their TV
on go do something else go to the park
whatever and your videos just keep
playing and playing and playing but to
subscribe from a TV screen is really
hard
they have to get out their their remote
and click over it's just a really big
pain and so most people do not subscribe
from a TV screen so there's another
thing if we care about only views TV
screens are on if we care about actually
converting them to subscribers growth
for our Channel TV screens are off the
other three are all fine Peter's saying
it's cheaper to go everywhere is there a
country you've seen as cheapest
it'll be seven to ten times more
expensive
to Target these countries
seven to ten times more expensive
you don't care and you just want views
and subscribers and real people you just
you don't select certain countries you
just go all countries and territories
India will definitely be number one
just because they're so huge and
everybody's on YouTube there and they
all have their phones Etc then it'll
probably be Argentina Brazil South
American countries
um but it'll be seven to ten times more
so it's like of course I want these
countries of course but do you want to
pay seven to ten times more ooh okay
maybe not
so that becomes uh there's not again no
right or wrong answer it's just what
fits for your goals for the organization
and how how much you prioritize
conversion versus just The Branding of
having X number of subscribers on your
channel okay so that's in-stream versus
Discovery right we want Discovery and
those are some of the settings to pay
attention to to help you save a lot of
money almost everybody gets this wrong
if I'm looking at somebody's campaign
they always have TV screens picked off
they sometimes have countries picked off
um they're making a lot of they they
almost always have these all three
clicked off and you're just basically
losing money
with those settings this will save you a
lot of money get you better results if
you want to see this full video as well
as trained live with me twice a month to
blow up your brand join the brand Linux
training program there's a link to join
right there next to me continue to
believe I'll see you there